In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for July 12, on which we commemorate St. Veronica with
the issue of blood, who was healed by Christ and who died in peace.
St. Veronica came from Cessaria, Philippi, Paneas.
She was healed by our Lord Jesus Christ of a flux of blood which had afflicted her for long
years.
In Thanksgiving, she had a bronze statue struck which represented Christ stretching
out his hand to a woman kneeling before him at his feet on the plinth, where this
inscription was written, to God, Savior of the world, a plant grew that was able to heal
all sickness.
Veronica placed this statue in front of her house so that all who passed by might venerate
it and keep present in their hearts the memory of its model, the God-man.
Having passed the rest of her life in holiness and in a manner pleasing to God, she fell asleep
in peace to rejoice before the face of the Lord forever.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
and save us.